so you started a book club so Britney
what's up with this book club we heard
you started insulting them like in
Earnest trying to put together this of
like here's what Britney's been doing
lately yeah so what's up with that book
club yeah you guys like [__] tell me
about the book club sounds so sad I
actually am interested in the book Cody
does read I do read books I know that's
why we put it on there I know no no I'm
not making fun of you guys I'm making
fun of us yeah I'm saying I'm saying we
have this beautiful topics Doc and yeah
we devolve every time I am making fun of
them chaos and depravity it's just
because Noelle can't read he's mad yeah
because you don't know how to read yeah
that and I've gotten this far so why am
I gonna switch it up now what does that
say right there on the wall do you know
what that says
that's no idea think about you every
episode looking at the top of stock
being like cool yeah
I'm like I'm wondering why you're not
sticking to it every single week
you can't see it damn that's okay yeah
so I've been reading uh hey hold up you
you said my squirting joke was bad but
look right here Britney pees her pants
when she laughs
yeah wait that that's a new chair so
yeah yeah I'm pissed it's not the Mr
Beast chair I better not be too pissed
all right don't rip a piss in the
[__] right yeah
so you wanted to sit on the same couch
as the Mr Beast yeah just to say I did
and I was gonna sneak it into my car and
sell it all right I feel like anything
he touches has to be worth something
yeah he's kind of he's kind of on that
level isn't he yeah I'm gonna sell like
used Mr B's tissues yeah
thank you how did you get those
yeah what the [__]
[Music]
Mr Beast panties
Mr Beast underwear
lightly shot in jeans yeah now you know
Mr B's walking around in a thong all the
time that'd be straight up g-string like
hanging out this is sick yeah what
[__] movie was that in that was in
Gremlins it was in Shrek too none oh
[__] was it Gremlins thank you yeah
there was that there was Pinocchio God
damn it what old movie was I watching
recently
I think it was Gremlins
no [__] he's
sure yeah this guy this guy goes for
report a crime
and uh
oh nah it was um A Christmas Story with
Chevy Chase
he like goes in yeah I'm holding the is
that the that's the vibrator for like
the [__] ring yeah
what are you playing with right there
can you really call this a cut like is
that a [__] actually
well it stretches out Lifesaver gummy
really I'm not gonna touch it
I don't know it was here overnight I
don't know if I don't know what happened
with that
he's wearing ladies under so what was
the movie Christmas Vacation no way it
was uh it was it was one of those that
Chevy Chase I think and and the dugo's
like report a crime and he and he heard
this rumor that
uh the oh [__] no
sorry I watched it take longer though I
will I'll take as long as I want it's my
goddamn show um
I made the last seven minutes this
laughs
No One's Gonna say [__] about it because
I'll make them all feel bad
okay no it was it was a Christmas movie
that Danny DeVito did it's really bad
Deck the Halls so Dane DeVito and
Matthew Broderick they're like competing
with decorating their houses because
Matthew broderick's like the local like
Christmas guy and then Danny DeVito
comes in he's like a scammer he's like
nah I'm the Christmas guy
this is this whole thing but so
basically Magic broder's character goes
to report a crime and he heard that the
head of the police station was a a
cross-dresser as they referred to it in
the movie
and then he's as he's reporting the
crime he notices like this guy's got a
bra and he's like what you looking at
he's like oh nothing I and the guy tells
on himself he's like you thought I was
wearing a bra or something
buttons up his thing
and then as they're having a
conversation he's like okay let me turn
around and look into what you're talking
about he turns around he bends over and
his whale tail comes out I love that and
then Matthew Broderick just walks out
the room because he doesn't want to
acknowledge it yeah that was a really
cool story thank you
hey I left I think I would have
preferred silence
okay
I'm kidding no no we can do that too
that guy at the party that's like well
everyone wants me to go home anyway
they're being insufferable do you know
the story of Chevy Chase have you Edina
like the lore behind him like being
hated awful yeah yeah I I went to
there's a Reddit uh what's the [__]
Reddit it's like it was a wet it yeah
yeah it was it's the most bacon [__] of
all time it's called like uh God damn it
I read a crazy story too about Warhammer
in that it's basically like for people
that are really into a certain thing and
they want to tell a story oh hobby drama
yes hobby drama that's what it is yeah
so you've been there yeah so yeah the
time was a voted post of all time when
this is about Chevy Chase and his roast
and it's just about how he was a total
dick his entire career and how nobody
liked him yeah but still kind of kind of
managed to succeed but like just pissed
everybody off that he worked with to no
end so that his his roast finally like
none of his close friends showed up and
it was all it was all like up and coming
comedians that he didn't know Stephen
Colbert was one of them and they all
just like tore into him because they
just like didn't know him wanted to make
a name for themselves wow I don't know
when you go back and watch some of those
like National Lampoon stuff he seems
like he's like a I don't know somebody's
acting you're like this guy's a [__]
dick yeah really like something comes
through in the performance or you're
like I just know when they stop rolling
he was still a [__] but do you think
that's like a little bit part of his
charm because I feel like that's kind of
what you're like I can't get a read on
this guy he's like he's not that funny
but weirdly he's super funny I think
there's a way to do it like a Robert
Downey Jr Ryan Reynolds where it's like
you know they're making fun of you the
whole time they're they're talking to
you yeah but they're pretty attractive
that's the well yeah maybe he should be
hot he could get away with a lot more
yeah if he wasn't ugly maybe he should
be young and hot so I like how I asked
who's the last straight dude you hung
out with and you showed us that like the
most attractive Canadian dude you could
pick like oh this is my straight friend
yeah he's just my straight friend I'm
gonna believe you hang out with a
straight guy when you hang out he has to
be like a five seven
gamer
relax with that what is this yeah we
don't qualify with that are you talking
about gesturing I'm just stretching my
wrist yeah okay
get a close-up
I'm a five eight gamer yeah five seven
we could never yeah imagine being that
short
couldn't be me it'll it'll be us in 20
years though when our spine starts
shrinking oh yeah I think it's already
happening yeah the back end right yeah
yeah I think it's me getting smaller
Jack does this bit where uh he pretends
to be small and annoying and it's like
so funny because he's not
I'm friends with them because he's I
mean he's got your sense of humor like
it's all you know kind of brands of the
same person I hang out with him because
like we're very similar but my followers
are like please put me on with Jack like
please I'm begging you on my bended knee
like let me and I'm like can we relax
wow they're like set me up with him yeah
wow like on a date like give me his
number put in a good word for me and I'm
like that's crazy yeah it's really wild
to be like yo love your content I would
like to [__] your friends your friend is
sexy because I'm like I know please
don't DM me does he does he live in L.A
just you know uh he laughs
well I'm wondering for the fans right
I started following him and I'm just
curious
because he's like typing out a message
does he live in L.A backspace
he's not here
um no he was in Toronto I don't know you
guys put your weird Visa [__] he like
can't be here yeah but he is yeah you
guys it's a bit weird piece of [__]
it's it's your guys's weird Visa [__]
it's not mine okay that's the Texas
right there yeah you're [__] yeah
yeah you [__] alien yeah
you're not supposed to be here but
somehow y'all always are sometimes weigh
in snap your little way over the Border
over the wall huh I guess you didn't get
enough Health Care up there had to come
down for a little bit more than that huh
you like your freedom don't you our jobs
did you yeah help yourself yeah you guys
love that
for [__] socialism with you
yeah I love Jack you guys would love him
too
yeah he seems like a nice kid so you
should hit hit him up for me would you
put in a good word